welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the
final trailer for morbius with jared
leto playing the living vampire proving
all it takes to slim down from house of
gucci to house of hong kong is a diet of
blood a film set in sony's adjunct
spider-verse even more confusing this
side of spider-man no way home so i'm
gonna break down all the new footage in
this final trailer to try to explain how
it all connects or how sony wants us to
think it all connects let's go
the trailer opens with shots from
morbius's transformation that we saw in
the boat sequence released back in
december in the comics dr michael
morbius is a spider-man villain with a
rare blood disorder that he tries to fix
with vampire bat serum and electro
therapy that turns him into a living
vampire not the immortal undead variety
from vampire lore this boat scene seems
based on morbius's introduction in the
amazing spider-man 101 in 1971 when he
was found at sea and attacked sailors on
a boat and then horrified by his actions
jumped overboard trying to commit
suicide but here more abuses attack
seems a bit more justified this looks
like it's after morbius's experiments
with bats in south america and continued
treatments from his fiancee dr martine
bancroft on their way home with those
shady contractors that he might have
partnered with to make this trip
contractors that i think might have been
hired out by horizon labs or maybe even
oscorp but unlike the full version of
this scene that we saw a couple months
back this trailer makes it look like the
soldiers are looking for in hunting
morbius when in reality they are fleeing
from him fall back
a shot has actually been added to this
trailer showing a flashlight pointing up
at the bulkhead and for a moment it
looks like the light might pass over
directly where morbius could be there is
some dark shape with some notes of
purple in there it reminds me of my
favorite shot from the 2005 horror film
the descent when one of those cave
divers points her flashlight at the cave
wall over what we think was just a
boulder but when the light goes back
over that spot a couple seconds later
the boulder has crawled out of sight and
no one says anything and among all this
carnage there's a very quick shot of
morbius's fangs rushing toward us but if
you slow it down you can actually see he
is upside down swinging at us and his
fangs really just glimmer in that light
moving on
michael
what have you done i was trying to help
people
butt the cure
so dr morbius treats a patient named
anna who presumably has a similar
condition that he has notice that
glowing blue medical tech that uses
matches the glow of the equipment that
he uses on himself signaling that more
beast isn't just selfishly seeking to
cure himself he is an anti-hero with
nobler motive she has a drawing on her
wall showing a sun perhaps a nod to
horizon labs which has the logo of a sun
rising over a horizon morbius cages
himself at the mouth of a south american
cave cutting his hands and attracting
bats with a kind of sonar frequency that
looks like it's emitted from this cage
somewhat evoking hooper in the cage and
jaws and i guess through some kind of
wacky science he's going to end up with
vampiric powers his helicopter has a tag
of
n9747p which is actually a common stock
registration number seen on aircraft in
a lot of movies like cars 2 casino
royale miami vice you know when we're
looking at the ipsu as a whole patrick
stewart may still have a bright future
of playing multiverse versions of
professor x ahead of him but that
doesn't mean you necessarily want to
copy his hairstyle two out of three guys
will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
but with keeps you can get quality
expert care without ever visiting a
doctor's office or a pharmacy keeps
offers generic versions of the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you never have to go to
a doctor's office keeps has a network of
expert medical advisors prescribers and
care specialists to support you in
making your hair goals a reality easily
subscribe to keeps and get refill
reminders so you'll never run low on the
products you need to take care of your
hair hair loss stops with keeps to get
50 off your first order go to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description that's k-e-e-p-s
slash new rockstars now morbius calls it
a curse and the audio sounds like it
might have actually been a response to
adrian tomb's line later in this trailer
we've been given a gift
not exactly it's curse which would
reflect the gift versus curse motif from
the first sam remy spider-man this is my
gift
my curse and then recently repeated by
green goblin and no way home when he
said these are not curses they're gifts
moving on spider-man
have powers that can only be described
as superhumans
but there's a cost
as the title reminds us this is the same
studio that gave us spiderman no way
home and venom we cut to another shot of
horizon labs verizon labs is a facility
where peter parker works in more recent
comics developing new suits like his
stealth suit the spider armor mark ii
and the spider armor mark iii which we
should note both showed up as alternate
designs in the stark tech fabricator on
tony's jet in spider-man far from home
designs that are probably still in the
archives of that same machine now in
happy's condo and no way home horizon is
presumably the lab where morbius
conducts his research in this movie and
or the shady partners who might want his
serum to weaponize for their own ends
oscorp also exists in this film based on
the shot of the building in the past
trailer it is the same tower and logo as
andrew garfield's amazing spider-man
films so the implication is that morbius
exists in sony spider-verse alongside
venom that's why he referenced venom in
the last trailer i
am i know and this could be in the same
universe where andrew garfield is peter
parker spider-man that would explain why
the first teaser showed that graffiti
calling spider-man a murderer and in no
way home that saint peter confessed that
he stopped pulling his punches and got
rageful now yes that particular art was
the rainy era suit but this is also like
fan art in the world not a photographic
representation of exactly what
spider-man has to look like in this
reality now how does the mcu michael
keaton vulture fit into that hold that
pot morbius rubs his forearm look
closely there's some dark veins on his
bicep that shift around under his skin
yuck then morbius activates his sonar
perception as a bus passes him in new
york's chelsea area its motion explodes
and a watercolor swirls as if from his
perspective everything is part of a
fluid network that he can hijack and
float through just like the visuals we
saw of him floating in front of that
subway car now we do know from set
photos that there is a city bus in this
movie with a daily bugle where is
spider-man ad but this is a different
bus just got an iheart new york on the
side of it different bus moving on now a
face of choice it's a hunt
and consume
blood don't die
we all have monsters within us
it's up to us to control it
what if i can't okay here morby's sonar
explodes across the whole city as he
runs along a building ledge with a
purple cape trailing behind him like his
purple cape in the comics then a
terrified nurse runs to her hospital
gets attacked by a vampiric claw though
this isn't necessarily morbius it could
be matt smith's character thought
initially to be based on loxi's crown
from the comics the character's name is
actually milo and he might also be based
partly on emil nicos michael morbius's
childhood friend and his first victim
meanwhile jared harris is playing
morbis's mentor and a caregiver to both
these boys when they were younger his
name is dr nicholas on to the next clip
michael morbis
you've been given a gift
not exactly
time to let go of what you used to be
discover who you're meant to
be okay michael keaton appears once more
as adrian toombs vulture who of course
last appeared in spider-man homecoming
which is in the mcu when he was also
wearing this same white inmate jumpsuit
in that homecoming post-credits scene
now again the mcu is a distinctly
separate universe than the universe of
morbius and venom so the simplest
explanation is that maybe michael keaton
is just the adrian tombs in every
reality much like how jk simmons is the
jay jonah jameson in every reality folks
it is either that or all of these
universes are secretly set after some
past multiversal reality warp that
resulted in our current inexplicable
anomalies redundancies and plot holes
and we've just been gaslit so we don't
remember what happened and now
multiverse of madness will fix
everything in a few months i mean i
don't know why marvel studios would care
to justify sony's illogical casting
decision but hey it just sounds like
they're counted on us not thinking that
hard about the logic which is always
worked great for the nerd movie genre
but here it looks like morbius and tombs
will share a prison cell a cell that
morbius is going to break out of which
probably will allow tombs to break out
as well moreoves gets slammed into a
neon sign for wyman hotel which could be
a reference to m.c wyman long time
artist from marvel comics notice how
morbius knocks off the m in the o maybe
he'll bump into a few other signs not
gonna lose an r a b an i a u and an s
spelling smirbio
moving on
all our lives we've lived with death why
shouldn't they know what it feels like
for a change
just accept who you are
the bad guy
young morbius and young milo the older
version of which will be played by matt
smith set beside each other in hospital
beds there are boys with the same blood
disorder that's how they met and it
sounds like the mutual torment they
faced as kids make them now parallel
figures with milo having gone through
this first the person who gave morbius
the idea to do it now but instead milo
has turned against humanity and notice
how he stands on the same subway
platform where agent rodriguez later
finds some bodies of cops i'm guessing
it was milo who actually killed them
another shot he cheekily points a nail
or a tiny stake at someone maybe this
was actually a stake projectile fired
out of that arm-mounted apparatus of
agent simon stroud tyrese gibson's
character weapon that might be designed
to deal with supernatural threats but
ineffective against science vampires
like milo then more ways gets blown back
on this rooftop with solar panels and
whereas his forward movement has always
been tailed with these purple wisps now
he's pushed back in a fluid stream with
hints of teal that might be the color
associated with milo's vampiric form and
in these swarms of bats you can actually
see two figures probably morbius
fighting milo bursting out of that
barrier over the heads of the
authorities on the final clip
holy water really
yeah you ever see lost boys story of my
life
so rodriguez places holy water in front
of a detained morbius holy water of
course being a known deterrent against
vampires according to vampire lore which
rodriguez references by citing the lost
boys a 19817 vampire movie jared leto
responds story of my life geraldo did
appear in teen horrors like urban legend
but notice how stroud has this scar
across his neck there was a shot in the
previous trailer where stroud was
holding his neck as if morbius might
have just grazed it or maybe milo did
actually the tag of the uk trailer is
different you don't look anything like
you do on the news yeah you look
downright robust pilates helps how can
they tell how fit he is when he's
wearing a hoodie like a hoodie is what i
wear when i go to pool parties so when
it comes to this movie's connectivity
with sony spider-verse i think the
overwhelming response to andrew garfield
and spider-man no way home has
reaffirmed sony's hopes of preserving
their own spider-verse independent from
the mcu populated with characters like
venom and morbius and soon craven the
hunter madame webb chameleon so michael
keaton as adrian toombs was an mcu
character but since sony was the
majority financier of spider-man
homecoming keaton's contract was with
sony not with disney maybe now we're
seeing this studio creatively reclaiming
the character by suggesting all vultures
in every reality just look like michael
keaton now i doubt we will see andrew
garfield cameo in this movie but it
wouldn't be that hard for this movie to
reference his existence with like a
daily bugle headline for photo credit to
peter parker or like a news ticker and
folks the craziest thing is if something
that simple were to happen in morbius
that might be enough for fans to forgive
anything else they don't like about it
to tell their friends that it is
essential viewing for every spider-man
fan so yeah it's easy to say sony might
not know their audience as well as
marvel studios does but maybe they know
us better than we think you can follow
me on instagram and twitter at ea boss
follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you